PLUS, PRESIDENT TRUMP MAKES A
STATEMENT BY CELEBRATING THE
NATION INSTEAD OF THE NATIONAL
FOOTBALL LEAGUE.
BUT FIRST, WE HAVE BIG BREAKING
NEWS FROM CAPITOL HILL.
FORMER FBI
DIRECTOR ANDREW
McCABE IS OFFERING COMMITMENT.
FORMER ATTORNEY GENERAL LORETTA
LYNCH TO TESTIFY WHEN THE IG
REPORT ON THE HILLARY CLINTON
EMAIL INVESTIGATION IS FINALLY
RELEASED.
REPORTING THIS.
THE FBI ESPIONAGE CHIEF HAS BEEN
VERY COOPERATIVE WITH
CONGRESSIONAL INVESTIGATORS.
THE SOURCE SAYS THAT STRUCK
PLAYED AN EVEN LARGER ROLE THAN
WE THOUGHT INITIALLY IN THE
CLINTON EMAIL PROBE AND THE
RUSSIAN INVESTIGATION.
LET'S DISCUSS ALL OF THIS NOW
WITH CONGRESSMAN RON DeSANTIS,
DEMOCRATIC STRATEGIST RICHARD
GOODSTEIN AND A FORMER DEPUTY
ASSISTANT ATTORNEY GENERAL
ROBERT DRISCOLL.
GENTLEMEN, IT'S GREAT TO SEE ALL
OF YOU.
WHERE DO WE BEGIN, LET'S START
WITH THIS IMMUNITY PLEA FOR
McCABE.
EVERY TIME YOU HEAR SOMEONE
CONNECTED WITH TRUMP WHO MIGHT
WANT IMMUNITY, IT'S LIKE, OH, MY
GOSH, YOU WANT IMMUNITY, YOU
MUST BE GUILTY.
WHAT'S GOING ON HERE?
JAMES COMEY STOOD TALL AND WAS A
MODEL LEADER AND NOW HE WANTS
IMMUNITY BECAUSE HE KNOWS HE'S
JEOPARDY WITH HIS CONDUCT OVER
THIS INVESTIGATION, BOTH THE
CLINTON AND THE TRUMP
INVESTIGATION.
I WOULD NOT GIVE HIM IMMUNITY, I
WOULD MAKE HIM GO, IF HE'S GOING
TO PLEAD THE FIFTH AMENDMENT
THEN HE SHOULD PLEAD THE FIFTH
AMENDMENT BUT THE IDEA THAT HE
SHOULD GET SOME TYPE OF GET OUT
OF JAIL FREE CARD FOR THIS IS
NOT SOMETHING THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE WILL WANT TO SEE.
>> Laura: RICHARD?
>> THE PRESIDENT SAID IN TWEETS
ABOUT McCABE, LIED, LIED,
LIED.
HE CALLED HIS WIFE A LOSER,
CLASSIC MOVE.
BIG --
>> WE HAVE VERY LIMITED TIME, I
WANT TO KEEP US FOCUSED ON THE
FORMER DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL
WANTING IMMUNITY.
IF HE HAD NOTHING TO HIDE A
COMPANY IF HE WAS A BORE AND HAD
INFORMATION TO RELEASE TO THE
MEDIA, WHY WAS HE ASKING FOR
IMMUNITY?
>> THAT'S ALL I'M SAYING.
WHEN THE PRESIDENT ASKED FOR THE
FIFTH AMENDMENT, PLEASE BRING
THAT BACK.
>> Laura: WHEN IS THE
PRESIDENT ASKING FOR THE FIFTH
AMENDMENT?
>> HERE'S WHAT I MEAN.
IF YOU HAVE AN PRESIDENT THAT
ISSUES PARDONS WILLY-NILLY,
McCABE WOULD BE OUT OF HIS
MIND NOT TO SEEK IMMUNITY WHEN
YOU HAVE SOMEBODY WHO IS AT THE
TOP OF THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
>> Laura: RICHARD COME HIS OWN
LAWYER IS SAYING HE'S CONCERNED.
>> HE SHOULD BE CONCERNED WHEN
HE HAS THE PRESIDENT GOING AFTER
PEOPLE LIKE CRAZY.
>> Laura: THIS IS A CRIMINAL
REFERRAL, THOUGH THAT WAS MADE
BY THE INSPECTOR GENERAL.
THE INSPECTOR GENERALLY THE
PREDICATE FOR THIS.
I GET IT THAT YOU DON'T LIKE
TRUMP.
IT'S A BIG NATION AND I'M GLAD
WE HAVE OPINIONS ON THE SHOW.
BUT THIS IS SOMEONE WHO IN A
NONPARTISAN CONSONANT
PROFESSIONAL INSPECTOR GENERAL,
HE BASICALLY SAID HE WAS
PREVARICATING, TO PUT IT KINDLY.
ROBERT, YOU CAN CHIME IN, YOU
HAVE EXPERIENCED, AND HE WANTS
IMMUNITY.
THIS IS A WILD SERIES OF
DEVELOPMENTS THAT WE HAVE HAD
WITH THE FORMER FBI DEPUTY
DIRECTOR.
>> AND SMART MOVE BY HIS LAWYER
BECAUSE IF HE GETS IMMUNITY BY
JUDICIARY THAN HE IS FREE FROM
PROSECUTION BY DOJ.
SO YOU'D RATHER HAVE AND
EMBARRASSMENT THEN DUE TIME.
IT'S ALWAYS A TRADE-OFF BETWEEN
TRANSPARENCY AND JUSTICE WHEN
THE CONGRESSIONAL COMMITTEES AND
DOJ ARE DECIDING WHETHER OR NOT
TO GRANT IMMUNITY.
HE WOULD HAVE TO SAY EVERYTHING
HE KNOWS AND EVERYONE WILL HEAR
IT.
I THINK THE CHAIRMAN WOULD HAVE
TO WEIGH THAT AGAINST WAITING TO
SEE WHAT HAPPENS IN THE
DAY-TO-DAY PROSECUTION WHICH
WOULD TAKE ADDITIONAL MONTHS.
>> I THINK ALSO, DOES HE HAVE
EVIDENCE, THERE ARE AT LEAST
SOME REPORTS SUGGESTING THAT HE
MAY HAVE AFFIRMATIVE EVIDENCE.
COMEY SAID HE DIDN'T AUTHORIZE
THAT SO IF HE WAS PRODUCING
SOMETHING LIKE THAT --
>> Laura: BUT HE ALWAYS BACKS
UP COMEY.
BEFORE, WHEN THE TRUMP
CONVERSATION WITH COMEY AT THE
WHITE HOUSE, HE BASICALLY SAID
IT, HE BASICALLY SAID TO ME WHAT
HE PUT IN HIS MEMO AT THE FILE.
>> ON THE LAKE, YOU SAID HE
APPROVED IT AND HE SAID HE
DIDN'T APPROVE IT SO THEY ARE IN
DIRECT DISAGREEMENT ABOUT THAT.
SO THIS IG REPORT, THE PRESIDENT
OBVIOUSLY VERY FRUSTRATED.
AGAIN, I WOULDN'T BE TWEETING
ABOUT WHY IT WAS DELAYED BUT THE
PRESIDENT IS GOING TO TWEET.
BUT ON THE ISSUE OF THE IG
REPORT, WHY DO YOU THINK THIS IS
DELAYED?
WE KEEP HEARING IS GOING TO BE
OUT EVERY DAY.
>> THAT'S A PROBLEM, LAURA, WE
HAVE A BUREAUCRACY THAT IS NOT
ACCOUNTABLE TO EVERYBODY.
SO WE HAD ALL THESE MAJOR
PROBLEMS AND THE DEMOCRATS WERE
THE ONES WHO WANTED THE REPORT.
IF IT TAKES A YEAR AND A HALF TO
CONDUCT AN INVESTIGATION IT'S
NOT JUST -- YOU NEED A SPEEDY
TRIAL, YOU NEED A SPEEDY
RESOLUTION.
SHOWS 500 PAGES, COULD THAT
REQUEST FOR IMMUNITY HAVE SOME
RELEVANCE HERE IN THIS DELAY IN
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL REPORT?
>> I THINK PEOPLE ARE OVER
BLOWING THE DELAY.
WHEN THE REPORT IS DONE,
EVERYONE REPRESENTS SOMEONE WHO
HAS BEEN MENTIONED IN THAT
REPORT, THEY GET TO REVIEW IT
ALONE IN A ROOM AND NOT TAKE IT
WITH THEM AND THEY HAVE A WEEK
TO GET BACK WITH ANY COMMENTS TO
THE IG WHO THEN DECIDES WHETHER
OR NOT TO TAKE THEM INTO
ACCOUNT, OR NOT.
SO THE FACT THAT TWO WEEKS AFTER
IT'S DONE IS ABOUT ON TIME --
I'D BE CONCERNED IF IT TOOK
ANOTHER WEEK OR SO BUT RIGHT
ABOUT NOW IS WHEN IT SHOULD BE
COMING OUT, IN MY EXPERIENCE,
FROM WHEN THE REPORT IS DONE TO
WHEN YOU WORK THROUGH THAT
PROCESS.
THIS IS THE CIRCUMSTANCE AND
THERE ARE LOTS OF HIGH-POWERED
LAWYERS INVOLVED AND MAKING
OBJECTIONS.
>> Laura: A LOT OF LAWYERS
MAKE A LOT OF MONEY HERE.
>> I WANT THIS TO COME OUT AS
SOON AS POSSIBLE BUT I HAVE
DIFFERENT REASONS.
ONE I THINK WE WILL HEAR WHAT
RUDY GIULIANI WAS GETTING AWAY
OF THE SOUTHERN DISTRICT FROM
FBI AGENTS WHICH ALLOWED THEM TO
BASICALLY SAY BEFORE IT HAPPENED
THAT THE SECOND COMEY LETTER WAS
GOING TO COME OUT.
SECOND, I THINK WE WILL SEE THAT
HE ACTED INAPPROPRIATELY BUT IN
WAYS THAT HELP THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
HE SAT ON INFORMATION ABOUT THE
RUSSIAN INVESTIGATION, AND THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN, AND HE WAS WAY
OUT THERE IN WAYS THAT BROKE THE
RULES BOTH IN JULY AND OCTOBER I
WHAT HE SAID ABOUT THE HILLARY
EMAIL INVESTIGATION.
SO, I'M WITH YOU.
I AGREE, I HOPE IT COMES OUT
TOMORROW.
>> >> Laura: WHAT DO YOU GUYS
THINK ABOUT THIS NEW TEXT?
IT'S A TEXT BETWEEN PETER STRZOK
AND LISA PAGE.
NOW WE LEARNED THIS TODAY
BECAUSE THIS WAS RELEASED AS
PART OF THE 500 PAGES OF TEXT
RELEASED BY THE SENATE TODAY.
HERE'S WHAT THIS LOOKS LIKE.
IT SAYS, HE WILL GET OUR LURES
ARE APPROVED, WHICH IS FBI LINGO
FOR SPIES.
SO THE QUESTION TONIGHT, WITH
THESE SPIES POTENTIALLY SENT IN
TO TARGET THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN
GOING BACK TO DECEMBER OF 2015?
AND IF SO, THAT COULD BE FAIRLY
EXPLOSIVE, COULD IT NOT,
CONGRESSMAN?
BECAUSE COMEY SAID, THIS
INVESTIGATION BEGAN IN JULY.
THAT TEXT, AGAIN, AND WE WILL
LEARN MORE, AND THE HOUSE IS NOT
EXACTLY WHERE THE SENATE IS ON
THIS.
BUT WHEN YOU READ THAT TEXT, IT
CERTAINLY APPEARS THAT THEY WERE
LOOKING TO PUT MORE LURES INTO
THE CAMPAIGN IN 2015.
SEVERAL PEOPLE ARE REPORTING
THIS TONIGHT AND WE WILL LEARN
MORE, I BELIEVE.
BUT WHAT DO WE THINK ABOUT THAT?
WHY DID THEY REDACT THAT WORD?
IT INITIALLY CAME OUT AND IT IS
LIKE, OOPS, IT SAYS LURES THERE.
>> SO THE QUESTION IS WHY WOULD
THAT HAVE BEEN REJECTED?
I THINK THIS IDEA THAT
CROSS FIRE HURRICANE STARTED
THIS ON JULY 31ST, CLEARLY
THAT'S NOT TRUE.
YOU HAD COMEY, McCABE AND
LYNCH DECIDING NOT TO BRIEF
TRUMP IN APRIL WHEN THEY WERE
SUPPOSEDLY CONCERNED ABOUT
CARTER PAGE.
YOU HAD STEFON HALPER REACHING
OUT TO THE CAMPAIGN BEFORE THAT
SO THIS DID NOT JUST START ON
THE 31ST OF JULY.
>> I THINK HE HAS EXPOSURE AS A
RESULT OF THAT TESTIMONY.
I DON'T THINK HE WAS TELLING THE
TRUTH THERE.
>> SO IS THERE ANY WAY HE
WOULDN'T HAVE KNOWN, IF THIS IS
TRUE, THAT IT STARTED EARLIER?
PERHAPS IN MAY?
SO HE IS LIKE THE HEAD OF
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE AND PETER
STRZOK WEST'S NUMBER TWO.
NOW HE HAS BASICALLY SAID STRUCK
WAS BASICALLY THE MAIN GUY IN
BOTH THE HILLARY AND THE RUSSIAN
COLLISION INVESTIGATION.
OBVIOUSLY HE WANTED HILLARY AS
PRESIDENT AND HATED TRUMP WITH A
PASSION BUT, HE TRAVELED TO
LONDON IN MAY OF 2016.
THAT WAS, AGAIN, TWO MONTHS
BEFORE THE CROSS FIRE HURRICANE
STARTED.
>> I'M GOING TO DISAGREE WITH
THE CONGRESSMAN ELEMENT HERE.
WHAT'S TWISTED ABOUT THIS IS AT
THE END OF THE DAY, STRUCK
DRAFTED THE COMEY LETTER BEFORE
THE ELECTION.
HE ALSO SAID BAD THINGS ABOUT
ERNIE, CHELSEA AND HOLDER, IN
ADDITION TO TRUMP.
THE SAME THINGS THAT MARCO RUBIO
AND TED CRUZ WERE SAYING DURING
THE CAMPAIGN.
THE FACT IS, FBI, WHEN YOU LOOK
BACK, THEY HELPED TRUMP BY
SITTING SITTING ON INFORMATION
ABOUT HIM.
>> THE REASON THEY PUT THE
LETTER OUT WAS TO PROTECT THEIR
OWN BEHIND.
STRUCK WANTED TO PROTECT HIS
BEHIND AND COMEY'S BEHIND.
BUT ONCE HE CAME OUT AND GAVE
THE PRESS CONFERENCE, A KIND OF
HAD TO GIVE THE LETTER.
>> >> Laura: .
WE WILL LEARN MORE BUT THEY
REDACTED THE WORD LURES.
AGAIN, LINGO FOR SPIES.
FBI'S DON'T USE THE WORD SPIES
BUT THEY USE THAT WORD.
NONCONTIGUOUS UNIDENTIFIED
INFORMANTS.
SO, THAT ACRONYM, AND THEN LURES
WAS UNREDACTED.
SO AGAIN, YOU GET ALL OF OUR
LURES APPROVED?
I LOVE THE LITTLE SMILEY FACE.
AND YOU KNOW, IT GOES ON FROM
THERE.
>> I THINK THE TIMELINE IS THE
MOST DAMAGING THING HERE BECAUSE
PEOPLE ARE USING A BUREAUCRATIC
TERM WHEN THEY SAY COME
INVESTIGATION WASN'T OPEN.
WHILE THAT MEANS NOTHING IF
THERE WAS INVESTIGATIVE ACTIVITY
GOING ON BEFORE THE
INVESTIGATION WAS OPENED.
SO EVEN THE FBI SAID, SOME OF
THESE CONTACTS FROM OUR
INFORMANTS/SPIES OCCURRED
LEADING UP TO THE INVESTIGATION.
WELL, IT'S KIND OF LIKE, DID GOD
CREATE THE EARTH?
WHO CREATED THAT, WHO CREATED
THAT?
BUT SOME WHAT HE HAS TO
APPROVE -- >> Laura: REMEMBER
THIS THING WAS SUPPOSED TO HAVE
BEGUN KIND OF SORT OF WHEN THAT
LIST OF TRUMP FOREIGN POLICY
ADVISORS, NATIONAL SECURITY
ADVISORS CAME OUT, CARTER PAGE
AND GEORGE PAPADOPOULOS, THEIR
NAMES WERE ON IT IN THE SPRING
OF 2016.
BUT IF THIS GOES BACK TO 2015
AGAIN, WHAT WERE THEY WORRIED
ABOUT?
I MEAN, STRUCK -- THEY WERE
PETRIFIED OF TRUMP.
WHO KNOWS, MAYBE THEY THOUGHT HE
WAS GOING TO CATCH ON.
>> ONE OF THE PAGES IN THE TEXT
WAS, POTUS WANTS TO KNOW
EVERYTHING WE ARE DOING.
>> CAN WE JUST ARE NEVER THAT WE
HAVE HAD A WHOLE SEGMENTS ON
SHOWS LIKE THIS ABOUT THE STRUCK
SECRET SOCIETY COME ABOUT STRUCK
LOST EMAILS?
LET'S TRY TO FIGURE OUT
EXACTLY -- I AGREE WE NEED TO
GET TO THE BOTTOM OF THIS.
>> Laura: I'M PUTTING CAVEATS
AIM, AND I AGREE WITH YOU BUT
THOSE ARE TECHNICAL ACRONYMS
THAT ARE USED WITHIN THE BUREAU.
THOSE AREN'T LOVE MESSAGES
BETWEEN THE TWO OF THEM.
I'M SURE PEOPLE ARE FASCINATED
BY THOSE, BUT THOSE ARE
TECHNICAL TERMS.
SO IT SEEMS LIKE, DID YOU GET
APPROVAL FOR THESE LURES?
AND, WAITING FOR THE ANSWER.
>> BUT THERE WERE NO SPIES.
THERE WAS ONE GUY THAT MADE A
COUPLE OF APPROACHES TO PEOPLE
THAT WERE TARGETED BY CIA AND
FBI.
>> ONE HOUR PEOPLE HAVE COME OUT
WITH ALSO STEPHEN MILLER BEING
INVITED TO THAT SAME EVENT.
>> PAPADOPOULOS AND THEN THEY
REACH OUT TO SAM CLOVIS, AND
HERE'S THE THING.
IN "THE NEW YORK TIMES" AND
THEIR BIG ARTICLE, THEY SAID AT
LEAST ONE PERSON SO THERE IS THE
POSSIBILITY THAT THERE WAS MORE
THAN JUST STUFF ON THE HALTER.
>> SO IT LOOKS LIKE THEY WERE
TRYING TO GET ALL OF THE
EX-ASCENT NATIONALISTS.
STEPHEN MILLER IS REALLY A
RUSSIAN PLANT.
BUT AGAIN, THE TIMELINE IS IS
IMPORTANT BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE
DOCUMENTS, DO WE?
WE DON'T HAVE A LOT OF FBI
DOCUMENTS FROM THAT TIME.
BEFORE JULY 31ST.
THAT'S WHY YOU ARE GRADUALLY
GETTING THE TEXT.
>> WE HEARD FROM PAPADOPOULOS
AND OTHERS THAT THE RUSSIANS
WERE TRYING TO GET DIRT ON
HILLARY, BUT NOT ONE PERSON IN
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN WENT TO THE
U.S. AUTHORITIES, NOT ONE.
THAT'S A FACT.
>> Laura: DO YOU THINK THIS
PAPADOPOULOS -- THIS CHARACTER
ACCOMPANIES TROLLING BARS IN
LONDON AND GOING TO TRUMP TOWER
AND SAYING, I'M GOING TO SET UP
THIS.
>> I THINK WE HAVE LIKE, THE